foreign
let's go to Mark in Savannah Georgia
what's up Mark
hey Dr John party and how are you I'm
part of you do good good to hear it man
what's up
well hey uh so a couple months ago you
had an episode where a woman called in
and she
and she had bought a farm and we're in
the process of fixing it or just trying
to make the farm life work and I
actually listened to that as we were
doing some work on our farm to close on
it because we were in the same boat
um and kind of working on escaping from
it and we're out of that now we're in a
new whole situation new life which is
much better
um I guess I just kind of wondering how
to move forward and kind of fix some of
the issues that came up from all that uh
everything we went through within that
what issues came up
so the the kind of situation was we
bought this old rundown Farm the house
needs fixed up the whole property needed
a lot of work so it was just a lot of
time and energy going into that okay
hold on that means before that
did y'all have a dream
yeah then so it's been our Dream for a
long time to to have a farm and raise
our kids with animals and and have it be
you know a peaceful the the quiet Farm
life that we kind of
have you ever been on a farm
that's basically a farm yeah
good point but yeah that was something
okay how long have y'all been married
uh 10 years okay so that's a long time
of watching HGTV videos and YouTube
videos and like going through Zillow
over and over again like right
yep yes okay so you got this Farm you're
gonna Fix It Up You're Gonna Learn you
can just YouTube everything and it just
it's a nightmare right yeah
Hey listen here's what I'm laughing at
work before but here's what I'm like I
live on a similar situation and my wife
grew up that way and so I had the luxury
of being like here's what we're gonna do
and she's like you're an idiot that's
not how that's gonna work at all and uh
anyway I was just on the phone with the
guy just before this call I was on the
phone uh before the show started with
the guys who came out to service my well
and something in our spring I literally
have no idea what they're talking about
but I nodded and I was like yeah that
sounds great so good good for you okay
so disaster you'll have this dream y'all
think about it you plan together you you
dream together it's just gonna be this
Blissful thing where animals just
peacefully die so you can eat them and
crops just grow themselves and it always
rains okay so here you are
then what
so yeah we got into it we started doing
the house which I I had some background
doing that work as well so I wasn't
quite as as naive I guess maybe as he
made out to be well it's not that if
people know how to people know how to
hang drywall and fix joists they don't
know how to do that and be married at
the same time
sure that's the difference so on and on
top of that I was starting a new
marketing company which is my
why not why why wouldn't we do that that
sounds fantastic excellent good job and
we have three kids that are under seven
absolutely why not oh it was just it was
just everything piling on you know as as
you're uh pointing out there and I I as
you can imagine we got to the point
where we were just gonna implode if we
didn't change something and and we kind
of powered through all of it obviously
it was stressful basically from day one
and we kind of powered through
um I find myself I found myself kind of
having the dynamic of I'm gonna be the
strong one and put on a bold face and
not you know show that I'm struggling
with this and my wife was kind of
opposite and struggling a lot through it
all and going along with it just uh
kind of make me happy or may try and you
know make the dream continue to work and
whatnot
um but it was slowly just go into a
really bad place and we finally got to
that Breaking Point instead
and it's kind of more heard telling me
you know I can't continue this or I have
to get out of the situation because
everything feels so unhealthy that
we got to get away from it so good for
her we finally did and and yeah you know
we feel so much better being away from
it but it's just we going through all
that put us in such a weird place and I
feel like now we we're almost we know
that there was some trauma and a lot of
hurt from that
it's just hard to identify what it even
is or talk about it I feel like a lot of
times it's hard for us to even just talk
and we'll just watch something or look
at our phones to kind of sure build the
silence it's hard to even know you know
where to begin
thinking through all this stuff as well
so did anything happen that caused a
rift did you cheat on her
or no did she did you say something to
her did she hit you I mean is there
anything like of that nature that
there's these unspoken elephants in the
room that we got to address
thank you
no nothing I know not an unspoken thing
the only thing is you know she got to
the point where she said if we you know
I was kind of continuing to try and
build my my new business and make the
dream work like I said I was kind of
putting on the brave face and she was
more than one kind of saying this isn't
working and she got to a point where she
said
you know if if you're gonna keep
pursuing this I have to leave and I will
divorce you okay and that's and that was
kind of like that really was the
breaking point for me to think okay it's
either the dream or my marriage and I'm
you know halfway going to choose my
marriage so all right are you are you
are you happy about that choice
yes 100 okay when a guy tells me he's
putting on a brave face
What I Hear in my mind is I'm leaving my
wife
I am unplugging from her
and I am surrounding myself in a in a
sheet of iron so that I can just plow
ahead
and when I do that she is unplugged
she's untethered I've left her I might
sleep in her same bed I might eat at her
same table but I have left her in
pursuit of and so what she was
identifying was you've left me I'm just
gonna make it for you
is that fair
and absolutely most of the time I don't
think guys want to do that I think y'all
y'all got in a dance right I've got to
keep this thing going she's like I gotta
keep this thing going and both of y'all
were waiting for the other person to say
I'm out right and so she was just gonna
formalize it
often so here's a couple of things when
you think of trauma you failed at a
thing
and that's okay have you ever failed at
anything before did you ever get an F in
school or get fired from a job
yeah a few times okay so this is uh uh
my boss Dave says
um all success is built on a pile of
failures
and so it's setting back and saying okay
we had this dream we were and it's the
death of a Dream It's the death of a
picture of who y'all were gonna be right
yeah and so you have to acknowledge you
gotta grieve it here's what we wanted
and that's not gonna happen
and until you do that
most people skip that step and then go
okay well then we're gonna live a
Suburban life and do this and you're
gonna find yourself with two 2024 Tahoes
that you can't afford in a big house you
can't afford and you're gonna be trying
to start another business and right you
can be running and chasing instead of
saying
we both really wanted this life and it
wasn't what we thought it was cracked up
to be and we both realized we don't talk
as well as we thought and we both
realized and she gets to say here's what
she realized
here's what she learned about her
husband
and you get to say here's what I learned
about my wife
and here's our new reality we got to own
that and then we get to decide what is
it going to look like next and you're
going to be tenuous to I mean it's going
to feel awkward to build a new dream
because y'all built one and it imploded
on it yeah is that fair
yeah yeah and so here's a here's another
thing
um
you've probably heard me talk about
pictures and words a lot the reason I
think reading is so powerful and my wife
is a was a was a literacy scholar the
reason I think reading is so important
because it allows every reader to read
something
and they concoct the picture in their
mind and when we watch something on TV
it says it looks like that it gives the
spoon feeds us the picture here's where
that's important
you said we wanted this peaceful life
where we were all together and you
started creating sentiment behind a
picture but HGTV told you what that had
to look like
sure and instead of that I would rather
you go back to the values the principles
the feelings that you thought you were
going to get by this having this life
and try to build that wherever you are
so we want a peaceful life we want an
off-grid life we want a
um an accomplished life where we do
things together you see what I'm you see
what I'm getting at you can do that in a
three-bedroom two-bath house in the
middle of some Rando suburb sure you can
get off the grid and get solar panels
and turn your backyard and your front
yard into my friend Pete did that he
just plowed up his whole front yard and
planted food there my friend Alex did
that in his backyard it's just awesome
so you can create that life wherever you
are but HGTV doesn't the one responsible
for what that ends up looking like you
and your wife are
right does that make sense and so it's
going back and saying okay how do we
rebuild this thing let's start with what
we want this to feel like and look like
and let's go from there sure yeah I know
that that totally makes sense I think
that's something we've kind of started
looking at And discussing and yeah
trying to figure out what's at the core
behind why we wanted that and how can we
achieve that so I think that definitely
makes sense where can I be super honest
with you
yeah I feel like you're not telling me
something
what is it she's she she almost walked
out why what was at the core of that
I think you hit it when you talked about
what it means to put on a brave face
with the kind of main issue that came up
that she's just saying I need more
communication okay and and yeah I wasn't
you know I wasn't communicating her with
her because a lot of what I would tell
her is hey this one project didn't go as
smooth as I hoped it would or this is
going to cost more money or this is
worse than we thought it was
um did you hear did you hear how that
translates to my husband's lying to me
yeah
see what I'm saying
yeah and that that un untethers
relationships when somebody I mean
there's a few things that make somebody
feel unsafe when they know somebody's
keeping secrets from them
right because we usually don't keep
secrets of great stuff going on
yeah have you sat down and said I wasn't
honest with you and I'm sorry and I'm
healing from that I tried to hide stuff
from you and I should have done that
have y'all had that conversation
not I mean not directly you know some of
that stuff came to head and then I kind
of had to say oh well here's what you
know here's how this is actually what I
didn't quite tell you all of it
necessarily and and we kind of talked to
you know that I told her you know the
reason I did it was a try and you know
save you the stress of having to worry
about it but I I maybe we haven't
necessarily claimed it as what it was
well that's that I mean again I want you
to hear that how she hears it
um I'm the grown-up here and you're the
child I'm going to protect you from it
you don't worry your pretty little head
and she's probably pretty smart right
yeah oh yeah and she probably considered
herself an equal so here's where all
this heads
I would love for you to sit down
and write an honest letter to her
we are now how how long has it been
since you moved
uh three months now I think okay so we
are three months out 90 days ago we
finally got out of a mess
and we dreamed about this mess
and we dreamed about this life that we
were gonna have and now that particular
dream is over period
here's what I realized I did over that
time trying to keep that dream alive I
didn't tell you the truth
I left you I was absent I got more
focused on trying to save the business
than I did trying to connect with my
wife and my kids and and of all the
things
all right
and then I want y'all to go out and I
want you to read that to her
and the end of that letter is something
along the lines of I'm ready to start
building something new when you're ready
because you don't want her to feel
pressure to get up and start creating a
new thing
when she's still wrestling with the last
time I created something I was told I
was a child and I was left in the dark
and almost lost everything
that makes sense
yeah that does it's that magic I just
just we talked about the last call this
is vulnerability this is you saying I'm
sorry
and I'm ready to get back in the game
when you are and not pressuring her or
this I mean you're all in a good
situation right now job wise home-wise
all that yeah we are yeah absolutely
much better okay there's not a rush
and it is six months a year of just kind
of being and then discovering what comes
next
yeah can you wait that long
I think so I think we kind of got burned
out on
going for it as hard as we did so we're
kind of we're kind of a point where yeah
the relaxing and and taking it easy
sounds good for a little while and
here's here's um
trying to think of
so this will happen again
one or both of you will fail at
something in the future
we're not trying to live a failure-free
life that's not a goal that's not
something I'm going I mean I want to
minimize failure I want to be smart
about it but it's going to happen I'm
going to do all some baseball I mean
some football coaches call the exact
right play the right statistically
speaking the right the the momentum
everything's right and it just doesn't
work the play doesn't work the guy falls
down that somebody doesn't guard this
right whatever happens
you're gonna fail the goal is okay
what can we do different next time so
that we don't get caught in this dance
that we end up way in debt we end up way
in a hole we end up having to lie to
each other and one of you ends up saying
I'm out
so here's an example I'm going to be
very uh 30 000 feet here because I want
to honor my I don't want to just air my
dirty laundry out but
um my wife and I went to dinner the
other night and what normally would have
been a three or four month three or four
months
of me like doing the silent treatment of
me like and then her responding to the
silent treatment with going very
introspective trying to do we went to
dinner in like in 45 minutes we figured
it out
because I stopped it way up I said hey
here's how I'm feeling right now and I'm
being vulnerable putting this out on the
table and it makes me feel awkward and
weird because I'm a grown man from Texas
I don't like talking about this stuff
but here's how I feel right now and she
said oh gosh hey I'm sorry you feel like
that way b i 100 get where you're coming
from
and now let's figure out what we do next
and it literally was 45 minutes so yeah
that's not the issues the issues were a
big deal they were a big deal
it was the it was the strategy and the
skill set heading into that that just
made it a pretty relatively uh um
it's gonna sound super weird it was an
intimacy forming conversation
it's one of those that you got done with
it were like that was I'm glad we did
that I had that conversation yeah now I
feel even better about our relationship
instead of it being a three month ordeal
and uh oh she's gonna leave me all that
stupid stuff see what I'm saying yeah so
what are the skills y'all can walk away
with I think that's where we're heading
into this thing and maybe you when you
in this letter you tell her I'm gonna
commit from this point forward I will
never keep a secret from you again
I will always commit to telling you when
things are great and I will commit to
telling you when things are tough
I'll also commit to listening
and I'll always commit to keeping you
informed here's what it's going to look
like I would propose once a week we're
gonna have a budget meeting and a
calendar meeting and a check-in how are
you doing how are things going
and ask her what would be a good gift to
you in this season and by the way those
gifts will change the seasons will
change but right now
what is what's the best way we could
plug back in
and let her speak into it and commit not
to doing your own thing to fix it but to
listening to her and helping meet her
needs as y'all figure this thing out
moving forward
um
congratulations I'm proud of you man
y'all went for it you got in the ring
and you saw the biggest dude there and
you swung as hard as you could you just
he just hit you back right and that
happens that's life I've got a
uh man I've got a trail of failures in
my life
um
that's part of it it's part of it